BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
ALI AFSHAR: Google Drive SDK
Google developer live session.
My name's Ali, and
this is Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Good
afternoon, sir.
ALI AFSHAR: And today, we're
going to be talking about
sharing in Google Drive,
sharing, and permissions, and
what the model looks like.
And finally, we're going to
finish with a bit of code to
show you how it works.
LOUIS GRAY: All the geeky
stuff, with some
real work mixed in.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah that's right.
Exactly.
So the first thing I want to
talk a bit about is a bit of
background on what is sharing
in Google Drive.
Well, Google Drive itself--
I'm sure you've all used it--
allows you to collaborate with
people on your documents.
In fact, I'd say this is one
of the most compelling
features of Google Drive, is
that it's all built in.
You share a link with someone,
and then they have access, and
they can look up the file.
In fact, they can
modify the file.
And you can all work
on it together.
Now, the Google Drive API allows
you to perform all the
functionality that you would
be performing in the user
interface, in Google
Drive itself, but
via a computer program.
So you can write code to manage
all those things.
So essentially, that is creating
permissions on files,
listing permissions on files,
deleting permissions on files,
and updating permissions
on files.
LOUIS GRAY: So just from the
very beginning, what are the
different types of applications
which live within
Google Drive?
I remember we recently
re-branded.
It started out as Google Docs.
And now we have Drive, which
has a number of different
applications.
Maybe you could walk us
through what type of
applications those are, and do
developers have access through
the API to each one?
ALI AFSHAR: So our goal with
the Google Drive SDK is to
cover all the functionality of
the Documents List API, and
perhaps add a bit more.
The kinds of applications that
would use this sharing model
are, if you can think of
enterprise applications where
the main administrator would
like to share a file with a
certain number of people.
Instead of going into the user
interface and clicking one by
one-- add this person, add this
person, add this person--
you can run a script that would
add all the permissions.
So you can imagine some kind of
document management system
within a company.
Everyone needs to read
this particular file.
Then the administrator can write
a script to do that.
LOUIS GRAY: And this works
across documents,
spreadsheets, presentations,
any other types of files?
ALI AFSHAR: So that's
exactly right.
Not only it works on the native
Google Docs files,
which are, as you said,
spreadsheets, docs,
presentations, drawings,
forms, and the others.
But also on any binary files you
save in your Google Drive.
So photos, PDFs, word
documents, all
this kind of thing.
There's one unified sharing
model across all of these.
So your application never needs
to think, is this a
Google Doc I'm sharing?
Or is this a PDF I'm sharing?
Or even, is this one of the
shortcut style of files that
we have in Google Drive?
A folder is an example
of that.
You could share folder
as well.
But from the API's point of
view, it's exactly the same.
You perform the same operation
across a file-like object.
And it will do the
sharing there.
Does that answer
your question?
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
When we look at this, I think
you'll go through the demo.
And probably some more
questions will
come up out of that.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, cool.
So let's have a look at
my neighbor's dog.
I really should probably learn
the name of this dog, because
I'm using him for examples
everywhere.
LOUIS GRAY: Let's
call him Benji.
ALI AFSHAR: Yes, let's
So Benjii, in fact.
Let's just edit the description,
shall we?
"Benjii" with two I's.
I like it.
LOUIS GRAY: All right.
Let's do it.
ALI AFSHAR: So I'm a user
of Google Drive.
I have a photo of this beautiful
dog, Benjii.
And I would like to share
it with someone.
I click on the "share"
dialogue.
And I enter my friend.
At dashertest.com.
This is Claudio.
If you've ever watched
our videos in the
past, you know Claudio.
So let's see.
So I just added Claudio
Cherubino at
dashertest to that.
And he can edit, or I can set
that so he can view the file,
or I can set that so you can
comment on the file.
These are important because
these are different roles
we're going to talk about.
So that's all I've done.
I'll save the changes.
And it's done.
I'm actually going to now take
that off so that I can show
you the equivalent operation
into the Drive API.
But let's just go over what
have we done here.
Well, from the API point of
view, we've added a permission
to this file.
And a permission has
three components.
The first one is the role
of the permission.
That's the action that whoever
is permitted access to this
will be able to perform.
You saw the options there.
They were Edit, they were Read
the File, and they were
Comment on the File.
There's another role
that is the owner.
That I own this file, because
I uploaded it to Drive.
So I'm the owner there.
So that's the first
thing-- the role.
The second thing is the type
of the permission.
Now, a type is kind
of like a scope.
But you can give a permission
to a file to either a single
user, a whole domain, such as
the google.com domain--
all users under google.com--
or to the general public.
So the type of the permission
defines the scope.
So in this case, I gave what
we call a user permission.
So that was just for
a single user.
So we've got the role, the type,
and then finally the
value of the permission.
The value is the user, or the
domain, or the public, or
whatever that I granted
access to.
LOUIS GRAY: And in this case,
you only gave access for one
user to one single
individual file.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: And you're going to
go ahead and show us that
using the API.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly right.
So just to show you there's
nothing up my sleeve, you can
see, I've removed that
permission there.
Nothing up my sleeves.
So let's just go ahead and
do it, straight away.
Why not?
So let's start a Python shell.
Now, as usual, I've created
my own auth module
that handles auth.
So I don't have to show you
my user credentials.
So, From auth import http.
There it is.
From apiclient.discovery.
We're going to, in the usual
way, build Drive
service using discovery.
We pass the name.
We pass the version.
And we pass our authorize
HTTP instance.
And we should have
a drive object.
There we go to that.
So first thing I'm going to do
is find the file that we want
to deal with.
You may already have the file.
You may need to get it.
So drive dot files dot list
dot execute items.
So this is going to get
the whole list of all
the files in my drive.
And I'm going to
get the items.
Those are the individual
elements and the response.
And I'm going to get
the first one.
And I'm going to
read its title.
How about that for
a long command?
LOUIS GRAY: Incredible.
ALI AFSHAR: Ta-da!
0.jpg.
Those of you are astute, you
know that that was the file I
was dealing with.
So this time, I just want the
ID of the file, because I'm
going to use that ID, then,
to apply permissions.
And I'm going to store it in
a local variable called
myfileId, so I never have
to look that up again.
So my file ID has got the
ID of the file you
want to deal with.
That's the files feed.
Now, to perform permissions
operations, you need to use
the permissions feed,
which is here.
Drive.permissions.
Now, I'll show you a little
trick of the Python library.
You can just do
drive.permissions.
And you can set that to value.
And we've got this perms.
And if I press dot, then I get
full code completion on that.
So it shows me all the
operations I can do.
First thing I'm going to do
is list the permissions.
So permissions.list.
And always, when doing any
permission operation, you need
to pass the file ID.
And you can see here, in my
beautiful code completion,
that it tells you, file
ID, string, the ID
for the file required.
So fileId equals myfileId.
And we execute it.
And there we go.
So we get a list of
these permissions.
Now, you can't exactly
see that, so we're
going to print it nicely.
Using the pretty print module.
If you don't use this,
it's really
useful for showing stuff.
Right.
So there we go.
So we can see that the
permissions feed has a list of
items in there.
And each item corresponds to
one of the permissions.
And you can see we've only got
one permission in here, and
that is for me.
OK?
Because I uploaded the file.
So it's got my name.
And it's got the
role that I am.
And I'm the Owner role.
I can actually transfer
the Owner role
using the same method.
But let's now add Claudio.
So perms.insert.
In fact, should we make the
permission object first?
So, as I said, the permission
object has three things.
So the type, which we said was
user, because we're giving it
to one user.
The role--
well, let's make Claudio
a reader first.
OK.
And the value, who is C Cher--
is it CCherubino or
ClaudioCherubino?
We'll soon know.
So that's the permission.
Now, we do perms.insert.
So we're going to insert
the permission.
We always have to give
the file ID--
myfileId.
And then we pass the permission
that we just
created as a body.
Because it's a post request
this time, and so that's
always post.
And we send it.
And ta-dah!
It was created.
So in the return, we got
the new permission
object that was created.
And we can see that
it's gone away.
And it's resolved Claudio's
full name
from the email address.
This is really useful, because
you can then, in your user
interface for your program,
you can display his name.
And then, if we list all the
permissions again, we should
be able to see these.
Permissions.list.
In fact, let's print
it nicely.
So we should see now that
we have two permissions.
Maybe you can't see that because
of the scrolling.
I see both you and Claudio
have access to that file.
ALI AFSHAR: So now both of us
LOUIS GRAY: So we have
a couple questions.
One person was asking--
you went ahead and demonstrated
this using a
Python shell.
ALI AFSHAR: Sure.
LOUIS GRAY: So they're
very curious.
What other languages can
you use to interact
with the Drive API?
For example, PHP.
What can you do to go ahead and
create an application that
impacts our API?
ALI AFSHAR: So we have client
libraries for all the
languages almost.
Obviously not all
the languages,
but the major languages.
And we have samples to do this
exact functionality in, I
think, eight languages
or seven languages.
So if you use Java, PHP, .NET,
Python, Objective-C, Go,
JavaScript, Ruby--
who have I missed out?
LOUIS GRAY: That's about
all of them.
ALI AFSHAR: So if you use
one of those languages--
LOUIS GRAY: Did you get .NET?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, we got .NET.
We never forget .NET.
We love .NET developers.
We love you.
If you use one of these
languages, the client library
is not only there, but the
surface you use is almost
going to be exactly like this.
So the list method is going
to be called List.
You might have to create the
body in a different way.
But you can use any of
those languages.
Furthermore, this is just
a simple HTTPS request.
It's just a post.
So, in answer to that,
Louis, you can write
your own client library.
Or you can use your own
language you invented.
As long as it can make web
requests-- and most languages
these days can--
then you can use that to create
these permissions.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, we just did
a demo of sharing a single
individual file with a single
individual user.
But often, there are questions
like, how can you get access
to an entire folder?
Is this enabled through
the API as well?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
So that is enabled
through the API.
Now, when you share a folder,
all the files
within it are shared.
So this is one of our
best practices
that we really recommend.
If you have 100 files, and you
want to share them with 100
people, well that is kind
of a painful operation.
But if you put all these files
into a single folder, and you
share that folder with everyone,
then you're going to
be absolutely fine.
They will all get
access to that.
LOUIS GRAY: How soon until your
voicemail is directly on
Google Drive there?
That would have been straight
into one thing
and sync this up.
I'm curious about one piece.
You're talking about sharing
a lot of your content.
As for me, I'm somebody
who puts a lot of
my content on Drive.
And that can a shopping list
from the wife, or a to-do
list, that can be
our kids photos.
Because I know that I can get
my content in the cloud no
matter where I go.
So with that type of thing
comes questions around
security or permissions.
And so what you've shown me is
the capability to go into a
script and give access
to more files.
What can I do as a user?
Or maybe you can tell me how
an application can get
permission to access my drive?
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
So that is a slightly
different thing.
And that's based authorization
for APIs.
So what you haven't seen here--
and perhaps I should go
through it, so you
can see how.
But what you haven't seen is
the authorization step.
So at some point, this
application has asked me, my
user, can I access your
Google Drive?
And I've said yes.
And then it's got a token
from Google, and
it's stored that token.
And it's using that token
to make the requests.
So this is really the
user authorizes your
application to do stuff--
step one.
Then the application does
stuff, part of which is
authorizing other users to be
able to read that file.
OK?
LOUIS GRAY: So I can make an
application that goes willy
nilly through everybody's
folders and
downloads all of it.
ALI AFSHAR: Absolutely not.
That would be--
LOUIS GRAY: A bad thing.
ALI AFSHAR: --really bad.
That would be really bad.
LOUIS GRAY: I just wanted to
make sure we covered that.
I know in some of our previous
GDL sessions, we've walked
through that authorization
token.
I think it's one of Claudio's
favorite phrases.
And now that we're at this
point, now that we have the
authorization that's already
taken place, now we're getting
deeper into the code of how you
can really impact that API
and hit the permissions.
Not only for files, for
folders as well.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
Well, let's have a look.
Did it work, in fact?
So you saw that there were no
permissions on this file.
But if I now go to it, and I
click on the Share button, you
see that the user I added
has actually appeared.
And he can view permissions.
So let's remove him,
just as a test.
And let's go back here and list
the permissions again on
the same file.
And you can see there's
only one person there.
In fact, we can see--
OK.
There's only me.
If we do another insert--
but this time we're going
to make Claudio be a
writer on the file.
So now, actually, Claudio
can change the file.
Same value.
Role--
writer.
Whoops.
See what happens when do you
live demonstrations, Louis?
LOUIS GRAY: That's how
they know it's live.
ALI AFSHAR: Role value.
Type.
OK.
And we do the insert,
perms.insert.
File ID equals myfileId.
There you go.
So we're inserting again.
But this time you see
that it's got the
same permission, Claudio.
But this time he's a writer.
And how does that translate
in the user interface?
Well, let's close this dialogue
down and let's
re-open it.
And you can see, he
can now edit.
So this is how the permissions
model maps directly onto what
you've got on Google Drive.
And you can do all these
operations with Google Drive.
It's just one way is
the user interface.
And the other way is
through the API.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, one thing I
noticed, in terms of the way
that Google Drive is a little
bit different, is it
automatically recognized your
permission changes, and you
didn't even have to refresh.
We've gotten away from that
model of refreshing to get the
new permissions and
pull them in.
But a lot like Drive, captures
every keystroke as
you modify a file.
It also manages to recognize
the permission changes that
were done through the API,
without you having to hit F5
or refreshing your browser.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
Modern web applications.
We're a long way away, now,
from the server web page.
Every time you get
a web page, the
information can be updated.
Google Drive itself, when you
can look in the explorer
console in your web browser to
see all the traffic going on.
There is a huge amount
of stuff.
It's all very dynamic.
Lots of little bits, lots of
browser channels, and that
kind of thing.
As I said, I'm not giving
away any information.
You can just go and see
all the traffic
going back and forth.
But I'd say, these days, to be
a well-behaved modern web
application, you would
actually have
to do it like that.
LOUIS GRAY: So we were talk
about the Drive API.
Now, is it new?
I mean, Drive, in terms of a
Google product, is fairly new.
We've had Docs around
for some time.
And I know earlier, we talked
about the Documents List API.
First, what's different between
the Drive API versus
the Documents List API relative
to permissions?
And the second, is
it new overall?
ALI AFSHAR: So yes,
it's new overall.
Reasonably new.
We launched earlier this
year, I'll say.
The Drive API is new.
It's a new surface.
But actually, it's built on
fairly mature technology that
brought you the Documents
List API.
And the Documents List API went
from version 1, 2, 3.
And the Drive API is pretty
much version 4 of the
Documents List API.
Overall what has changed is--
well, the main thing is the
architecture on which
the API lives.
And that architecture allows use
of nice things, like all
the automatic degenerated and
up-to-date client libraries,
excellent documentation,
that kind of thing.
So it was a really an upgrade
to the Documents List API to
move it to this better
architecture.
How has it changed in regards
to permissions?
Well, one tiny little thing
has actually changed.
And this we're seeing is quite
a big impact for both
developers and users.
So I'll take a bit of
time to explain it.
Now, when you list the
permissions, I can show you.
Or when you're looking
at a permission--
this permission object--
you can see that the name of the
user is there, and all the
other information.
But the email address of the
user is not actually there.
So you have this ID,
the permission ID.
That is this reproducible
ID that is very
specific for the user.
But there's no email address.
So before, with the Documents
List API, we were seeing that
the email address was available
in the permissions.
Now, why is that bad?
You might think it's useful.
But it's useful from a developer
point of view,
potentially.
But it's dramatically invasive
of a user's privacy.
Why?
Because you can see the email
address of all the other
people who have access
to a file.
So user A shares the file with
users B and C. And B and C
don't necessarily need
to know each other.
Now, by putting the email
address in there, we were
leaking B's email address to C
and C's email address to B.
And that's not exactly
what we wanted.
So now, we have this permission
ID that is returned
instead of that.
Now, that permission ID is
constant for the user.
So Claudio will always have
this permission ID.
That way, I can match up.
So I can make sure I can remove
his permission, I can
add his permission, do
whatever I like just
by using that ID.
But then the information
about his email address
is not being leaked.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, that permission
ID, as far as where
that's generated, is that
generated specifically for
this application?
Or is this, for example,
identified
with the Google profile?
If I were to take that string
and plug it into the Google
profile, would the other
user's ID come up?
ALI AFSHAR: No.
It's generated specifically
for Google Drive.
It is related to the user's
Google profile, yes.
Because obviously, we have one
system for managing users.
So it's related to that
and it directly
links to that profile.
But there are additional bits.
For example, you can share with
Google Drive a file to a
user that is not actually
a Google user.
So because of that, there has
to be some extra things.
So I can share it with
your Hotmail account.
LouisIsCool99@hotmail.com.
LOUIS GRAY: You got me.
You must have seen that, yes.
ALI AFSHAR: And even though
that's not a Google account,
you can still share
files with them.
So it needs a bit more.
But apart from that, it's
a similar concept.
OK.
Any more questions for me?
LOUIS GRAY: Not at this time.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, cool.
So we've gone over
permissions.
Just a little recap.
Firstly, the Drive API.
Anything you can do in the
user interface with
permissions, you can do
with the Drive API.
Drive has permissions
on files.
Each permission has a type,
a role, and a value.
The type defines the scope,
which can either be user, a
domain, a group, or
the whole world.
That's called default.
That means a public file.
The value is the email address,
the domain name, the
group name for that
permission.
And the role is what that person
or group of people can
do with the file.
That is, read it, write
it, comment on
it, or is the owner.
Now, you can add these
permissions purely by making
an insert request.
As long as you've got your
file ID, you make a
permissions.insert with
that simple body.
And it will generate that
permission for you.
Those permissions, as Louis
pointed out, are directly and
immediately reflected in the
user interface so that anyone
using that can suddenly
see them appear.
And using that simple method,
you can share files in your
Google Drive with anyone
using a script.
Oh, and we have examples in
all the major languages.
So go and check them out.
You should just be able
to copy paste them.
If you can't, let us know.
We're keen to have them all
absolutely perfect.
LOUIS GRAY: And not only that,
but we've done previous Google
Developers Live sessions in
practically every language.
And so we have a series
of events.
Writing your first app in Drive,
in JavaScript, Ruby,
Java, PHP, .NET, all of
those flavors that we
talked about before.
So if you're a developer who's
just starting to work in the
Drive API, we can
get you started.
And now you know how to share
permissions as well.
So appreciate that.
ALI AFSHAR: So take a quick
start guide that Louis
mentioned, developers.googl
e.com/drive/quickstart.
Take the one for your language,
and then copy paste
the sample from the reference
docs for insert and
permission, permissions.insert.
And you should be
able to go in.
Five minutes for the quick
start, two minutes for the
copy paste--
seven minutes, I reckon.
LOUIS GRAY: Not bad.
ALI AFSHAR: Not bad.
LOUIS GRAY: So anything else
for us, in terms of code or
preference?
ALI AFSHAR: No, that's
also the code.
If any questions have come
through on YouTube, I'm happy
to answer them now.
LOUIS GRAY: I'm seeing
comments on YouTube.
There are people excited about
ideas on their projects.
We've talked a little bit about
different types of languages.
We've walked through that.
We talked about sharing
folders and explicit
permissions.
So as far as live comments go,
I think we got them all.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, cool.
So if you have any follow-up
questions, were always on
Stack Overflow.
The tag is Google-Drive-SDK.
Send us a message.
Send me a personal email.
Happy to hear you.
If you have any problems,
really, really want to hear
from you, so that we
work through them.
There might be better ways
to do something.
We might have to improve
the API.
But please let us know,
and get in touch.
LOUIS GRAY: Thank you, sir.
ALI AFSHAR: Thank
you very much.
I've been Ali.
He's been Louis.
Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]